I take care of my mental health it's
definitely something that I prioritize
as well as my physical health I see a
therapist two days a week I reach out to
people that whenever I'm struggling with
something I you know I work out I eat
clean I have a healthy support system
around me so I do everything that it
takes to maintain a happy healthy
lifestyle I'm smelling so high right now
you all can't well you can see me now
but uh I'm happy for Demi and we all are
happy that she's doing better after
being in rehab for the last couple of
months let's chat with Brendan over at
the EP news desk for more on this
developing story from Brendan she was
spotted out and about can you tell us
where exactly she was spotted and what
was she doing Jamie had a busy weekend
around LA guys first sighting was on
Friday that we know of she was at
Halloween Horror Nights at Universal
Studios here in LA we know that Demi
attended with this guy that you see here
in this photo his name is Henry Levi
he's a fashion designer
we are told they've known each other for
a little bit now eyewitnesses that I
spoke to that saw the two at Halloween
Horror Nights tell me that she seemed
happy she seemed in good spirits she
looked very healthy which is obviously
very important so really good news our
second signing of Demi was on Saturday
night in Los Angeles that's actually the
the photo that you just saw there the
Levi's are Henry Levi's and Demi leaving
dinner in Beverly Hills
God we just saw video of Demi talking
about her health from 2017 and now
getting to 2018 since she's out of rehab
do we know how she's feeling since the
event over the summer and she continued
if she went to continue to live in Los
Angeles right so we know from sources as
of last weekend as of a couple hours ago
she's doing really well like you guys
mentioned here at the top she's been
sober for three months now a little bit
over that at the end of the day we know
that Demi is really doing this for
herself but she's also doing this for
her family and friends who do really
care about her one of those people is
her ex-boyfriend Wilmer Valderrama who
we know has visited her and
have our sources confirmed that he
visited her when she was in the
treatment facility outside of California
so he's been a supporter of her but we
do know that she's taking the sobriety
very seriously and she's in a really
good place right now as we've reported
in the past she is selling the Los
Angeles home where she did apparently
overdose in it's unclear if she's
staying in the LA area but we do know
over the weekend like like we just
mentioned here
she has been spotted in and around the
LA area you know this story really it
just does something to my soul because
it really could have went a whole
another way you know so to see her
thriving now and just back on top I know
she's just gonna kill it from from now
on but in the shot and the clip we
played earlier she talked about therapy
and how she goes to therapy two times a
week someone else who has been very
vocal about therapy is ariana grande can
you tell us about that Brendon yeah
absolutely an ariana actually was very
open about it very candid about this
this morning in a tweet she shared her
self-care advice when she responded to a
fan this morning on Twitter let me read
that tweet for you she says laughing my
ass off this is funny as f but in all
honesty therapy has saved my life so
many times if you're afraid to ask for
help don't be you don't have to be in
constant pain and you can process trauma
I've got a lot of work to do but it's a
start to even be aware that it's
possible very candid very candid just to
give our viewers some context I wanted
to figure out who was she responding to
and this tweet but someone basically
tweeted who was Ariana's therapist
because I need to see them ASAP it was
something along the lines of that but I
thought I agree because ariana has been
through so much and then with her recent
breakup with Pete and now she's still
out and about she's still public her new
song thank you next was just released
so whoever she's talking to it's keeping
her afloat because honey that's a lot to
go through
I know Brendon and Melissa a lot of
stars is in addition to Demi and Ariana
have definitely been vocal and open
about therapy you have Gwyneth Paltrow
who spoke about a meeting there appear
for proposed partum John Hamm who talked
about his chronic depression also
Kourtney Kardashian
who you know felt that she needed to go
to therapy as well so I just think that
it's when you have these stars that
aren't afraid to reveal when you reveal
you become so much relatable and there's
so many people who want to share in
their experience but feel judged because
we have let's keep it real there is a
stigma around not only mental health
depression anxiety but also a stigma
around therapy if there's a connotation
that you something is wrong with you
that you're not normal that you are not
that of the status quo so when these
stars speak on it I'm here for honestly
think everybody needs a therapy if you
had a silver spoon it does not matter a
therapist needs a therapist okay why not
have somebody you can talk to a not so
judged right when I thought one of the
Kourtney Kardashian one of the comments
she made in an interview was very much
about how you know what's the quote here
people are like it's so expensive and
this or that but you know it's more
important than buying clothes or a
handbag or shoes she's very open you
know if you need to help get the help
put the money towards it before you put
it towards other things like clothes
which we all love no that's that's very
true I mean because if your mind is
right and you're able to go to work and
be proficient in your mental health is
right you can probably get more clothes
than you ever would have thought of
Great Britain I'm so so much buddy thank
you thanks guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]